so it's been a wild year for y'all so
can you believe that you're grammy
winners did you expect that with this
album oh no i mean this started as a fun
songwriting challenge on tick tock and
you know we started writing music when
it blew up and the rest is kind of
history so it was not something we
expected at all yeah i mean even when we
released the music like it was just the
two of us and we had no expectations
like and there was no way in our head
that this could be
nominated you know what's cool about
that though is that you were doing
because you just loved it you're doing
something that inspired you it's created
you know creative and i think that's the
that's the fundamental of like what we
all do so yeah that's that's the base of
it so um you won best musical theater
album against people like bob dylan and
andrew lloyd webber so
did you did you meet them
yeah i mean like even when you say that
it doesn't sound real it sounds like
they're all of our idols so like to even
be on a list next to them is just crazy
but
the day that we got nominated was insane
because we were literally hanging out
with andrew lloyd webber all day long in
london and then we're having high tea
at the jury lane um
while we were watching the nominations
and then we were both nominated and it
just it feels like a fever dream yeah it
was like how are we in london
just hanging out with ambulances
yeah did you call him afterwards and go
i mean it's on
i mean i know you're andrew lloyd rubber
but now it's on
he is so supportive of young composers
so we love him cool i love him uh real
the talented genuine artists are um so
edina what tv show would you turn into a
musical if you could golden girl golden
oh my god oh that's really cool that's
brilliant oh my god
see i thought we were like the same age
because mine was designing women
i just want to hear that dixie carter
monologue like a song form um that's
amazing and you probably have never seen
it
so it's fine it's fine i'm always trying
to get rolls that i know i'm going to
grow in
i'm putting it out there
[Music]
you